hallo leute hier wieder einmal wanne und
willkommen zu einer neuen folge ich
teste ein gericht aus einem anderen land
zum ersten mal was ihr mir empfohlen
habt ja dieses format klingt noch ein
bisschen zu lang ich weiß es müssten so
was knackiges sein wie schmeckt format
namenvorschläge gerne in die kommentare
heute soll es um russische küche gehen
und da habt ihr natürlich pelmeni
empfohlen und damit wir die richtig
russische stimmung kommen habe ich erst
mal ein paar russische snacks besorgt
wir beginnen unsere russische reise mit
birken wasser mit minzgeschmack yummy
ich habe von birken wasser das erste mal
gehört in palina rojinski sportcast den
sie zusammen mit chery david aufgenommen
hat und da haben sie wirken was er
getrunken ich weiß nicht ob es gesund
ist ob man dagegen allergisch sein kann
europa hat ich bin auf jeden fall er ist
im moment bin sehr gespannt meint es
riecht wie nokia also ein klares münze
drin aber okay brust ich bin doch alles
schmeckt gut es erinnert mich aber sehr
fit und ich weiß nicht ob irgendwas an
eigengeschmack hat aber ich kann den
graf mich raus schmeckt jetzt bin ich so
richtig russisch eingestellt dann habe
ich im supermarkt noch dieses gebäck mit
kondensmilch geschmack gefunden
klingt alles typisch russisch
kondensmilch geschmack ja
die schmecken bisschen wie short brett
was aus england kommt nur ohne diesen
krassen buttergeschmack und ich finde
das eigentlich ziemlich gut und um das
alles noch abzurunden probieren wir
jetzt noch kringel gebäck oder wie die
russen sagen würden die kinder bahn hart
rita hammer de haan oder das war lecker
wenn ich ein tee trinkt gewürdigt so was
auch essen wollen treffen uns zum tee in
moskau aber sehr hart darauf dass man
gegen schlucken wasser als ich danach
gefragt habe was so ein typisch
russisches gericht ist ist mir
aufgefallen dass alle länder aus der
ehemaligen sowjetunion so ihr eigenes
spezial maultaschen gericht haben
sowjetunion warte mal das erinnert mich
doch an etwas erinnert ihr euch noch an
diesen ort in der sowjetunion wo dieses
kernkraftwerk stand was explodiert ist
tschernobyl und da fällt mir doch glatt
ein dass ich erst letztens eine serie
geschaut habe die genauso heißen kann es
sein dass wieder ein sky entertainment
angebot für euch habe ich bin wieder auf
sky ticket einen probemonat 599 starten
und mit den sky entertainment ticket
könnt ihr euch serien anschauen wie
tschernobyl
game of thrones rockin dead und noch
ganz viele andere game of thrones hat
übrigens den zwölften emmy bekommen und
tschernobyl hat auch seinen ersten emmy
bekommt für die beste miniserie und das
finde ich auch sehr verdient ich habe
die serie tschernobyl vor ein paar
wochen mit freunden durch geschaut weil
wir immer noch so einem gamer für uns
zusammen serie gucken fieber waren da
haben uns gleich noch tschernobyl
hinterher reingehauen und es ist
wirklich eine verdammt gute serie es ist
kein wunder dass in emi gewonnen haben
und gerade weil es ein thema ist oder
ein ereignis was wirklich passiert ist
also tschernobyl weil es immer nicht
weiß da ist block 4 also das kraftwerk
dinge so und dann ist ultra viel
radioaktivität
in die atmosphäre gelangt das ist ein
thema damit habe ich mich in der schule
beschäftigt und habe halt ein paar
fakten dazu gelernt
aber die serie zeigt diese menschliche
seite dahinter hofer das versagen wie
konnte so etwas passieren
wie ist die sowjetunion mit dem ganzen
thema umgegangen
und das alles in so einer miniserie
diese wirklich gut also wenn ihr auch so
serien steht die so ein bisschen hinter
wahren begebenheiten auf sind dann ist
die serie auf jeden fall was für euch
schaut sie euch an wenn ihr tschernobyl
noch nicht gesehen habt ganz ganz groß
empfehlung hier von meiner seite aus und
das könnt ihr natürlich mit dem sky
entertainment ticket für vier euro 99
könnt ihr einen probemonat starten euch
die ganze serien reinhauen und ich
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß damit der
erste link in der beschreibung und in
den kommentaren ist auch immer ein link
da könnt ihr drauf gehen und ihr kommt
zum angebot
und jetzt gehts weiter ich glaube
mittlerweile kann keiner so schnell wie
ich es gern hätte er mit ticket sagen
wow hab ich ein geheimnis talent das man
reden kann für alle leute die versuchen
mit meinen videos deutsch zu lernen
und jetzt kommt ihr zu den zutaten für
die original russischen pelmeni für den
teig brauchen wir mehr
der job ganz genau 75 milliliter wasser
und mit krise sei und das war vor schon
und die zubereitung ist ganz einfach
mehl in eine schüssel machen ein
bisschen salz hinzufügen dass ein ich
vergessen und alles mit wasser abrunden
und jetzt nehmt ihr eure 54 fingers und
knetet alles mit der hand durch das ist
so ein schönes gefühl
das ist das erste mal dass ich mich
selber machen und sie ausprobieren auch
wenn sich der teig am anfang ziemlich
eklig anfühlt irgendwann wird er so
schön weich und wenn ihr keine schüssel
benutzen volt und könnt ihr das auch
richtig angeberisch auf der
arbeitsfläche machen das auch ein
bisschen praktischer dann könnt ihr da
wirklich rein kneten und dieses baby
legen wir jetzt hat 30 minuten ins bett
gute nach stellt euch mal vor ihr
bekommen für die schule so vielen
teigklumpen danke manchmal das ist mein
lieblingsessen man jetzt macht ihr eure
finger denn die sinnvoller teig und das
fühlt sich wirklich an
überall sind die therapie das cover
wirken wasser pause und nun kommen wir
zur erfüllung da brauche ich erstmal
einen schnaps ein original russischer
birken wodka oder wie die russen sagen
würden paare dp chs 3 k
kennt ihr noch früher die vergänglichen
namen dieser namen sieht einfach aus ist
schon gaming noch mit vertretern der
drei k der krasseste was solche leute
mal ist nur einmal im jahr war auf die
russische kultur das zarenreich und mein
lieblingsfilm anastasia brust ich meine
schmeckt nicht schlecht es ist immer
noch wodka ich bin jetzt auf jeden fall
war wie sind schnaps brauchte ich das
jetzt sehr sensiblen inhalt gibt trigger
warnung wenn ihr den anblick von
hackfleisch nicht ertragen können es
gibt einfach vor
da ich wirklich klassische mini machen
möchte habe ich mich dazu entschieden
die mit der freistellung zu nehmen und
dafür habe ich aber extra von der
fleischtheke gut 200 gramm rinderhack
genommen hat alle fleisch spezialisten
da draußen ist es besser wenn man es 103
steht geholt damit man das gefühl dass
es vielleicht auch einfach nur das
gleiche ist aber mein gewissen sagt mir
so ich habe es von der fleischtheke
geholt und das mach ich mir jetzt ein
schönes mädchen
ich bin hamburger wenn ich hackfleisch
sehen wir brauchen hackfleisch und eine
frisur ein schlückchen sahne bisschen
butter salz und pfeffer und wenn ihr
danach noch ein date habt dann macht ihr
ein bisschen knoblauch ein und so werden
sie zubereitet hier gibt das gehirn in
eine schüssel
danach müsst ihr eine zwiebel in kleine
stücke schneiden bei mir funktioniert es
man am besten mit wodka
was für ein toller liferay danach die
bedrohungen zwiebeln einfach zum fleisch
geben
super für die figur kommt jetzt noch ein
schluck seine reihen und extra für die
kurven noch einen löffel butter
mit salz und pfeffer würzen und mit der
hand verkneten schuldige waren da kommen
leute wer fleisch essen will der muss
auch so was machen können und jetzt es
ist wunderschön es lustig dass ich habe
mich früher mit meiner mutter darüber
gestritten was ekliger ist teig oder
fleisch kneten und ich fand immer
fleisch kneten ekliger und sie fand teig
kneten voll eklig ich lag aber immer
noch bei tag und werden wir die füllung
gemacht haben konnte sich unser teig so
richtig schön ausruhen mache ich im teig
fühlt sich so viel besser an unglaublich
und jetzt kommen wir endlich zur
richtigen zubereitung und davor habe ich
besonders angst wir müssen den teig in
so eine rolle formen und ihnen dann mit
scheiben schneiden und ich würds mit
wodka machen aber mit messer geht es
auch so einfach
ich hoffe ihr habt diese tollen
geschmeckt schnitzels verpasst denn am
beach ist und jetzt nehmt euch ein stück
teig und macht es so zu einem planen ihr
könnt dafür auch so ein roller verwenden
und der hand es egal sie habe ich als ob
ich mich irgendwie damit auskennen würde
eigentlich sollte ein perfekter kreis
seien aber kommt leute und jetzt fühlen
wir diesen fahrten mit so ein bisschen
hackfleisch muss denn wie viele youtube
videos anschauen um zu checken wie man
es faltet also einmal so zu machen dann
habt ihr quasi in ravioli und jetzt
nimmt man diese entfaltet da so einmal
und mir fällt gerade auf wow
mein gott sieht eigentlich aus wie der
ab juli tortellini und kann das eine
historische linie und termine über das
gleiche einkommen für den ersten mal so
schlecht aus
davon macht jetzt noch drei millionen
weitere fleisch in das bettchen lege und
das baby zu decken alles schön zu machen
meine stimme
nicht mehr verwalten ist einmal zu ich
glaube ich hab ein naturtalent für
panini und jetzt haben wir zwei
ich wollte mal alle so weiter und dann
sehen wir uns gleich
[Musik]
belgiens und vorbereitet seid wie ich
bis jetzt euren topf und um unsere minis
zu kochen brauchen wir einen topf mit
wasser russland hausschuhe sind die
maschen jetzt ab otto maschen reputation
so mappus
okay wir müssen das wasser jetzt leisten
und weil bei uns in polen alles
irgendwie auch mit gemüsebrühe gewürzt
wird manche davon ordnungsmacht seien
einfach nur für den safe unsere p
minicom jetzt in das kochende wasser und
wenn sie nach oben strömt sollen sie
noch ungefähr zwei minuten länger im
topf bleiben und dann kann man sie
rausholen befindet sie unsere ersten
film i vj und jetzt kommt s ans
anrichten und dafür brauchen wir
laktosefreien schwimmen
wir nehmen zum guten esslöffel und
klatscht den so schön an diese hätten
und dann brauchen wir noch zum
auffrischen will nehmen aber ich liebe
diesen gefrorenen weil das hält einfach
für immer schaut euch das an
ist das richtig happy
mein geheimtipp alles schmeckt mit ein
bisschen zäh roger besser dankeschön ich
weiß ich bin einfach ein naturtalent
danke und jetzt stellen wir uns
natürlich wieder der allerwichtigsten
frage wie schmecken penny aus russland
guten appetit
die sind so lecker
[Musik]
es ist so lecker
ich habe natürlich noch einen richtigen
nachtisch vorbereitet in meinem
supermarkt haben sie dieses plombiert
eis was typisch russisch ist glaube ich
und bei mir haben sie sogar laktosefrei
und das hat mich so finden die auch
nicht glücklich gemacht
oh mein gott wie das süß aus wieder so
wie sollen diese sowjet kommunistische
version von prince of persia plombiert
haben wir ihn sowjetunion gäste dort la
strada ich probiere das x oh mein gott
es sich an ein polnisches eis ich merke
die russische küche ist voll was für
mich war wisst ihr was ich auch gerne
snacks essen wenn ich mit meinem sky
entertainment ticket serien schauen
ihr könnt es jetzt auch tun mit dem
probemonat von sky ticket für vier euro
99 und dann könnt ihr euch tschernobyl
anschauen und kaum wahrscheinlich so wie
ich richtig auf diesen russen weib und
mein gott russland ist so eine mut- also
klickt auf den ersten link in der
beschreibung dort kommt hier zum sky
angebot und ich freue mich dass ich
wieder mit euch kooperieren durfte und
da
damit hoffe ich hatte das video gefallen
und wenn ja dann tags mit einem daumen
nach oben
aktive die glocke damit ihr auch
wirklich kein neues video verpasst damit
es nicht irgendwo untergeht und schreibt
mir gerne aus welcher küche aus welchem
land ich das nächste mal vielleicht was
nachgucken soll aus welchem land kommt
ihr denn was ist so ein typisches
gericht schreibt einfach mal in die
kommentare und wir sehen uns beim
nächsten mal
und jetzt zum schluss gibt es noch ein
distanz
okay doch nicht alles ich muss aber auch
unbedingt noch die aus diesen so lecker